did your biological deadly the the
Hudson guy whatever isn't Bill Hudson he
had nothing to do with you your whole
life he was around when we were very
like young oh he was it sort of teetered
out you know it was like that lost
interest a little bit more complex I get
in touch with you after you were
nominated for an Academy Award no did
you begin to feel bad about yourself hey
how come my biological dad isn't
interested in me my mom never spoke
poorly of him and I was a real tough
little girl I did understand that didn't
have to do with me and Oliver we did
understand that I do really recognize
whatever those issues are are just
something that he has to live with and
that must be painful for him right and
so and I forgive him when I lay in bed
and I don't think gee must be terribly
doesn't know his grandchildren yeah he
doesn't know me and we'd be really nice
to have a relationship and have that
kind of love you know you you you do but
when you have a father like hurt you
know who's sort of been there for the
hard stuff
I'm not I'm not a big fan of armchair
parenting right you know and I think
that people can do a lot of things and
they can be very successful they can
still be a really good parent because I
was raised that way and Kurt was such
the thing is you know he's not a perfect
man like no one is but the trust that I
got from him in terms of his
dependability was was just priceless for
me